l'objectif pour moi quand j'ai créé ma
chaîne c'était de me faire des amis
j'ai malheureusement été victime de
harcèlement quand j'étais à l'école
[Musique]
et
je
quand j'ai mis 16 ans et que j'avais
vraiment pas d'amis j'avais j'avais ce
besoin de recommencer les choses à zéro
et d'essayer de parler à des gens qui
allaient me parler pour qui j'étais et
non pas pour ce que les gens avaient
entendu sur moi au début c'était du
lifestyle et de la beauté puis en
continuant je me suis rendu compte que
beaucoup de personnes se sont reconnus
dans mon histoire
beaucoup de filles notamment qui n'osait
pas parler du harcèlement qu'elles
subissent elles savaient même pas que
c'était elle savait même pas ce que
c'était le harcèlement elle n'arrive
même pas à poser ce mot sur ce qui leur
arrivait et quand moi j'ai parlé du mou
du harcèlement elles se sont dit ah mais
c'est ça que je vis depuis des années
est de voir que grâce à ça les gens
viennent me voir en disant merci parce
que si tu en rêves a parlé moi j'en
aurai jamais parlé à mes parents j'en
aurai pas parlé à mes profs
j'ai fait des tentatives de suicide et
des choses comme ça et quand on vient de
dire ça à moi je me dis que j'aurais pas
pu rêver d'un meilleur métier en fait
que de pouvoir aider les gens
[Musique]
j'ai créé mon propre métier donc ça a
été difficile au début et je me suis
beaucoup professionnalisé maintenant
j'ai deux entreprises gdg des
collaborateurs je travaille tous les
jours pour produire du meilleur contenu
et c'est sûr que c'est plus pareil
qu'avant mais en tout cas l'intention
elle est toujours là et c'est toujours
la même de vouloir aider les gens et
d'essayer de tout mettre en place pour
que quand ils viennent sur ma chaîne il
passe un bon moment et qu'ils arrêtent
de penser aux problèmes qui sont au
quotidien je pense que les gens n'aiment
pas vraiment les youtuber ou ou tout
simplement une très mauvaise image de
youtube heures parce que pour eux ce
n'est pas un travail personne ne réalise
l'ampleur du travail qu'il ya derrière
la recherche l'écriture des vidéos le
montage le bas tournage tout simplement
il ya tellement de choses que je cite
pas et il ya tellement de choses que
j'ai dû apprendre sur le tas à voir des
gens qui travaillent pour moi être
entouré avoir un avocat un comptable un
fiscaliste gérer tous âges et apprendre
à gérer une boîte quand à 18 ans moi
j'étais pas du tout destiné à ça les
gens ils sous-estiment vraiment la
fatigue mentale et la pression mentale
que youtube et les réseaux sociaux
peuvent mettre sur les youtuber bien sûr
on est content de pouvoir gagner notre
vie grâce à youtube moi j'en suis
reconnaissante tous les jours je trouve
ça incroyable si hier on m'avait dit que
j'aurais pu gagner de l'argent et en
faire mon métier je l'aurais jamais cru
je trouve ça dingue
[Musique]
je pense que quand on est une femme
toute sa vie on se pose des questions et
toute sa vie on a des remises en
questions sur notre corps sûr que mon
sens et même mois encore aujourd'hui à
23 ans j'ai toujours d insécurité est
des moments où je me sens pas forcément
bien mais ce qui m'a aidé en fait
surtout c'est de me voir aussi dans le
regard des gens qui m'aimait donc ma
famille mes amis peu importe le poids
qu'on fait peu importe la couleur de nos
yeux la couleur de nos cheveux et la
longueur de nos cheveux la qualité de
notre peau c'est ça peut paraître
bizarre ce que je dis pas ce que moi je
fais de la beauté je pars du principe
que ça nous aide à nous sentir mieux
dans notre corps mais la vraie vérité
c'est qu'il faut trouver quelqu'un qui
nous aime et pour qu'il en est vraiment